be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with ghostwriter Robbie ray as being
introduced in this season's Asians of
shield what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the powers of the
various ghost writers and Marvel Comics
and what I'm hoping is that by the end
of all this you'll be familiar with
their powers and abilities as well as
the similarities and differences between
each of them now while Johnny Blaze is
technically considered the second to use
the Ghost Rider name in level comics he
and the subsequent ghost riders are so
vastly different from the original Ghost
Rider Carter Slade that for the purpose
of this video we're going to put cutter
slight aside and focus on those
individuals who belong to the modern-day
family of ghost riders starting with
Johnny Blaze himself so while johnny is
an experienced stunt motorcyclist that
belonged to a traveling stunt show with
his adoptive parents crash and Mona
Simpson after learning that crash had
cancer
Johnny turned to the occult to try to
find some spell that would cure his
father as a result Johnny finds a spell
that allows him to summon the demon Lord
Mephisto who sells a soul in exchange
for the cure to crash his cancer
now while Johnny's soul would be saved
by the proclamation of love from crash
and Mona's daughter Roxanne Mephisto was
able to bond Johnny to the demons eros
and as a result johnny would be forced
to punish wicked people at Mephisto's
command and would turn into Ghost Rider
a man with a flaming skull whenever he
was in the presence of evil now in order
to accomplish this task johnny gained a
variety of powers that placed him among
the most powerful figures on earth one
of Johnny's most iconic powers is his
ability to control Hellfire a
supernatural energy that burns the souls
of its users victim while also retaining
the properties of regular fire in
addition to using Hellfire as a
projectile weapon and his early days as
Ghost Rider Johnny's motorcycle would
become engulfed in Hellfire but as his
control over the abilities grew he
gained the ability to construct a bike
entirely out of flame in addition to
traveling at extremely high speeds
Johnny's motorcycle is able to travel
across water and up vertical surfaces is
something to note here however is that
Johnny's powers are not limited to his
command of Hellfire instead he also
possesses several superhuman abilities
including agility reflexes speed stamina
and most notably super-strength as well
as having the ability to lift 25 tons
now in addition to super strength Ghost
Rider is made even more formidable by
the fact that he's virtually
indestructible and is seemingly immune
to attacks from any conventional weapons
as well as any spell meant to affect
living persons now in the rare case that
Ghost Rider does sustain an injury he
possesses entered
yes healing factor that's so powerful
it'll allow him to regenerate severed
limbs to this end all of this makes
Ghost Rider one of the most powerful and
dangerous forces in the world and in
fact in Ghost Rider number 13 a tie-in
to the world war hulk event Doctor
Strange posits that ghost riders powers
are nearly limitless and are only
constrained by Johnny blazes humanity in
addition to this once Johnny Blaze lost
control of the ghost rider dr. strange
explained that he would be able to go
toe to toe with the green scarf of the
Hulk although who chose not to engage
him in battle since none of those who
would be defending from the Hulk were
innocent and were therefore unworthy of
his protection a reference to the
Illuminati send me the hope to a far-off
planet against his will now following
Johnny's ten years Ghost Rider after he
captured xerath dose in the crystal of
souls a young man named Danny ketch and
his sister Barbara were attacked by
gangsters who actually ended up killing
Barbara as a result Danny carried her
body to a nearby junkyard where he finds
a motorcycle bearing a mysterious symbol
now when Danny touches the motorcycle
he's transformed into the ghost rider
something also note is that Danny
possessed many of the same powers that
Johnny Blaze had including superhuman
strength and control over Hellfire
however during Danny's tenure as Ghost
Rider under the writing of Howard Mackie
we see several new aspects of Ghost
Rider's power manifested one of the new
additions to Ghost Rider's Arsenal is
Danny's weapon of choice
the Hellfire chain first seen in Ghost
Rider vol 3 issue number one
Danny uses this ability to create and
manipulate Hellfire to transform an
ordinary chain into a weapon capable of
great destruction in addition to this
Danny is able to use the chain in a
variety of ways as he can transform and
other weapons can lengthen it will I can
separate into individual links that
Danny uses as throwing stars however
although Danny was the first Ghost Rider
that we see use this weapon after Johnny
Blaze becomes Ghost Rider again in 2006
under the writing of Daniel way he also
uses the chain as one of his primary
weapons the most significant addition to
those riders power set during Danny
catches tenure however is the pennant
stare first appearing in Marvel holiday
special number one in 1991 the pennants
there is an ability Ghost Rider uses to
incapacitate his adversaries by locking
eyes with them and peering into their
souls as a result victims of the
pennants there are forced to experience
all the pain they've ever caused anyone
else as emotional pain although this is
typically extremely effective there have
been instances when it's failed such as
when he use it on the Punisher who felt
nothing because of his lack of remorse
for his transgressions
against those he feels of deserving of
his wrath and venom who's incapable of
feeling guilt in addition to this the
penance stare has also proved
ineffective on people who were blind or
under the influence of drugs or alcohol
or if the victim has more than two eyes
preventing Ghost Rider from making
direct eye contact with them as a result
dependence there has also been used by
Johnny Blaze in his most recent time is
Ghost Rider although we see no evidence
of him using it during his original
tenure now moving on the most recent
incarnation of Ghost Rider and the one
that will be appearing in agents of
shield is Robbie Reyes although Robbie
shares several characteristics with
Johnny Blaze and Danny ketch such as
manifesting himself as a flaming skull
and using a flaming chain as a weapon he
is fundamentally different in terms of
the source of his powers while Johnny
and Danny are categorized as spirits of
vengeance due to their vow to protect
and avenge innocent victims due to their
possession by either a demon as in the
case of Johnny Blaze or the angel of
death and judgment in the case of Danny
ketch Robbie Reyes received his powers
as a result of his possession by the
spirit of a murderous uncle Eli Morrow
who worked for the Russian mob and
engaged in Satanism for this reason
Robbie is not a true ghost writer but
was accepted into the ghost writers by
Johnny Blaze now light previous ghost
writers Robbie can use Hellfire as a
weapon although his control over it does
not appear to be at the same level as
his predecessors and he has been known
to accidentally cause objects to burst
into flame
during his transformation into Ghost
Rider at the same time Robbie also
shares a link to his car that he'll
charger which allows him to teleport to
its location and merge with it as well
as use the trunk as a sort of teleporter
through which he can move people and
objects to any desired point if someone
also note here is that Robbie is capable
of teleportation himself when in Ghost
Rider form although this is done through
portal that he's opened and is not
instantaneous however due to the limited
number of appearances of Robbie Reyes
since his debut in 2014 is unclear at
this time if Robbie will possess the
ability to perform the penance stare
that we have not seen any evidence that
he can just as a side note if you want
to learn more about Robbie Reyes ahead
of his television debut you can check
out my video on him for a complete
explanation but with that being said
this basically sums up the powers of
each of the main ghost writers in the
Marvel Universe and so let me know down
in the comments section which version of
Ghost Rider you prefer and whether or
not you're looking forward to seeing
Ghost Rider coming up in Ages of shield
and I will catch you guys later peace
you
[Music]